la période électorale jours de marche et
même souvent avec politique
chalon sur saône ne fait pas exception à
la règle ainsi pour les candidats au
conseil général le lieu est
incontournable explications avec latics
au seul marché c'est là on rencontre les
gens le porte à porte c'est un petit peu
plus agressif consonnes en dérange sur
le marché c'est un lieu convivial les
gens se rencontrent se connaissent on
parle donc c'est le lieu idéal pour pour
partager avec la population les idées
qui sont les nôtres et puisse avoir des
postes et attendent de nous depuis 1992
date de sa première élection sur le
canton de chalon centre patrick forest
se félicite des trucs connus et reconnus
il arpente les échoppes accompagné de sa
suppléante est qu'il compte bien passer
le relais dans quelques années et en 26
ans de mandat il est toujours resté
fidèle au même programme
c'est l'aide sociale c'est le
développement économique c'est les
personnes âgées c'est les personnes
handicapées puis c'est l'école des
collèges
donc mon programme il est là alors rien
grand sujet de discussion c'est les
collègues justement puisque
vous savez que le président sirugue
fermer deux collèges à chalon ce qui me
paraît tout à fait impossible si on veut
promouvoir le développement économique
relancer l'emploi pour faire revenir des
populations plus jeunes c'est pas en
fermant les écoles qu'on va les attirer
pour trouver son principal adversaire
politique
il ne faut pas aller bien loin juste de
l'autre côté du marché et voici benjamin
griveaux ou 30 ans un tout jeune
candidat mandaté par le parti socialiste
pour lui pas facile de s'imposer face à
un adversaire inscrit depuis si
longtemps dans la vie locale
moi je suis un vieux chat un jeune vieux
chalonnais puisque je suis né et j'ai
grandi à chalon sur saône
j'en suis parti pour mes études et puis
pour débuter ma vie professionnelle j'ai
l'occasion de travailler pour dominique
strauss kahn pendant quatre ans à paris
et puis je suis chef d'entreprise
puisque je mets l'activité politique est
une activité dans le monde plus
économique
et c'est vrai que je pars avec un
handicap
un handicap que benjamin griveaux compte
bien effacer en faisant la différence
grâce à sion programme distribué dans
toutes les boîtes aux lettres du canton
une sorte d'avant goût pour la suite
depuis 26 ans le conseiller général
sortant n'a jamais fait un seul compte
rendu de mandat c'est pas ma conception
de la politique je pense que c'est une
conception qui est dépassée et que ça va
au delà des clivages gauche droite
d'ailleurs traditionnels je pense que ma
génération est très attaché à l'idée de
passer un contrat avec les électeurs et
qui dit contrat dit obligation de rendre
des comptes
donc moi chaque année j'irai dans tous
les quartiers de mon canton pour rendre
des comptes
expliquer ce que j'ai pu faire ce que
j'ai pas pu faire et puisqu'il faut
ajuster parce qu'un programme écrit le
mandat dure six ans des choses peuvent
changer
quatre autres candidats se sont
également lancés dans l'aventuré des
cantonales hr au centre viraux nique le
grand jean françois le guen guy thales
et claude bourgault
[Musique]